good afternoon my name is Graham Marco
and I'm a software engineer continuum
analytics where I work in the high
performance analytics group so part of
my job there involves am working on a
development at number and the other part
my job involves using them for
consulting to try and accelerate
customers codes so what I'm going to try
and do is share the benefit of some of
that experience in this tutorial so if
you want to start getting set up right
away you can grab all the tutorial
materials from this URL and there's the
slides and exercise and examples online
and there's also targeted and zip
versions if you want to download the
whole lot to your computer if you've not
already got anaconda or mini Condor
installed then you can install but then
i'd recommend that you get mini combi
and then use it to install number by
running condor install number there's
one or two of the examples that I've got
I think it have dependencies on side pi
and so I click image as well so you
probably want to store those as well as
everyone got this URL can move on to the
next slide in that Oh so for the
structure of the tutorial what I'm going
to try and do is do a very brief tour of
the features of number to give you a
sort of brief idea about it before doing
a few exercises to get familiar with it
then after a while I'll come back and
talk a bit more in depth about how it
works so on with the tour what is number
number is a tool that you can use to
make your Python go code go faster by
compiling and specializing it just in
time it's an opt-in tool which means
that it only compiles the functions that
you tell it you want to compile the
reason for that is that using them makes
a trade-off it has to relax some of the
semantics of Python code in order to get
better performance you wouldn't want to
necessarily make those trade-offs in
your entire code base you only want to
make them for the bits of code that you
care about accelerating so that's why
you only took two specific functions to
use it with the its development has been
focused on making it efficient for
numerical computation and array or
ented computing so a lot of the
trade-offs that have been made have been
focused on doing that also because it
can pass stuff just in time you can use
it interactively just as you would any
other Python code so these are some of
the practical details of the
implementation of number it's a
just-in-time compiler based dial of llvm
which is the low-level virtual machine
the reason we decided to use that is
because it's a fairly mature tool chain
and it's got a lot of inbuilt
optimizations there's a lot of different
other people using in their comparation
tool chains and it's cross-platform so
using that allows us to focus on the
specific aspects of compiling Python
rather than doing lots of low-level sort
of compiler work also because we use
llvm it means that we can target CPUs
and q2 GPUs so for the purpose of this
tutorial I'm only going to focus on the
cpu target because the GPU target is
only applicable to a narrower range of
codes and they all also doesn't hide the
parallel thread execution semantics of
the GPU so it's a little bit more
difficult to use it runs on it runs on
Python two and three on C Python so we
test with those versions and you can use
it side-by-side with any other Python
code or any see extensions that you've
got so you can use it in the same code
base as as numpy us and sci-fi or any of
the other tools from the PI data
ecosystem it's bsd license and it's
cross-platform so it should be fairly
easy to include within your own code
bases this is just a brief example of
the kind of speed up that you can get
using number if we take a pure python
implementation running on CP i-- thon as
a baseline implementation will say that
runs a one-time speed then there's
something you can some things you can do
to make it go faster just using dump I
for example you can vectorize it with
the ray wide operations but you can do
better user number so if you use the CPU
target for this problem they'll run 120
times faster than the baseline so you
can get an order of magnitude for you to
probe a number
this is one of those problems that does
work well on the GPU as well so you can
get a bigger speed up there so to
continue the Mandelbrot example this is
the code that was used with a number
version as you can see it looks it's
just normal Python code the only thing
we've done to use it with number is to
decorate it with this jit decorator now
when the mandal function gets called
instead of the Python source routing
number of jump in and run its compiled
version of the code so this is generally
how you would use number you take your
Python code and mark it with the JIT
decorator now there are some things that
you could earn some restrictions about
what you can do in functions that you
decorated with this decorator because as
I said earlier you have to make some
trade-offs to be able to get the
performance so there's some of the
things that you can do include all the
normal control flow so you can use
things like if else and all those other
statements you can raise exceptions from
jittered code and you can call all the
compiler functions as well so if you
have one function you've decorated with
jit you can call it from another justed
function and that call will be made
through native code there's no looping
back into the Python interpreter also
those other compiled functions can come
from see types or cff I as well and you
can use generators inside it it
functions there's some things you can't
do as well so although you can raise
exceptions you can't catch them so
there's no try accept or finally syntax
as a consequence of that there's no
context managers so you can't use the
with statement we haven't fed yet found
an efficient way to implement
comprehensions so they are not supported
ingested code and although generators a
supportive yield from in Python 3 isn't
supported the other limitation to be
aware of is that you can only detect
decorate functions with jit you can't
jit entire classes yet but that is going
to change in the next couple of releases
of number so these are the Python types
that are supported you can use these
primitives and anything that's like
herbal for like object you can use so
bytes or byte array as well
there's some built-in functions that are
supported which means that number
provides native implementations of these
functions that you can call from inside
zip code it's not just that it's not as
some built-in functions that are
supported there's also support for other
functions from the Python standard
library and some third-party libraries
as well there is a comprehensive list of
all the supported functions in the
manual that you can have a look at if
you need to check for a specific one
hello yes list on a list aren't really
supported no I mean you can use a list
but it will fall back to a slower mode
I'll talk a little bit more about that a
bit later so Oh as i said earlier a lot
of the focus was on a rail or into
computer computing so there's been quite
a lot of effort going into to support
for numpy features so you can use all
types of an umpire raised inside [ __ ]
functions apart from when you're using a
razr structured arrays but contain
python objects you can allocate arrays
inside dated functions and you can do it
eration and indexing and slicing those
reductions and you can use the scalar
types and values as well you can also
write array expressions inside edge
itted function but you can't use
broadcasting at the moment again there's
a list of everything that is supported
inside the reference manual so I've
talked about one way of using number
which is to use the JIT decorator the
other way in which you can use it is to
to use it to write number Universal
functions or you folks in Python so if
you're not familiar with with a what are
you from kiss essentially it's a scalar
function that can be applied element
wise to array arguments by a numpy
so when you write one of these scalar
functions you also get some other
operations for free that allow it to be
used in reduction and accumulation
operations the downside of Ryan you
function normally is that you have to
have to write them in see it compile
them or if you write them in Python they
can be slow but number provides a way in
which you can write them in Python and
have them compiled so you do this using
the vectorized decorator if you write a
Python function which takes scalar
inputs and returns a scalar output then
when the function is called with array
arguments number will take care of
compiling that scalar function to native
code but then umpire will take care of
applying element by element so you folks
can be useful for for my element
computations but sometimes you might
want to operate sub-array by sub array
or sub matrix x sub matrix so this is
where generalize you folks orgy you
folks can come in and you can also write
these with number they can operate on
are arbitrary number of input elements
so to declare to declare ogu from you
can use the g you vectorize decorator
which is like using vector eyes but you
would also need to tell tell number
something about the inputs to outputs to
the function so there's two things it
needs the first thing is to know is the
types so in this example the types of
all the two inputs and the output or in
64 the second thing you need to give it
as a layout specification which is this
string so in this example we're taking
ln length vector and a scalar take and
that go maps to an output of n-linked
vector that that's delimited by the
inputs and helpers are delimited by the
arrow notation now functionally there's
no difference between the inputs and
outputs the actual the only difference
between them is that inputs are
something that's passed in by the user
and outputs or something that gets
allocated during the time
at the time that they're called and then
a return to the user so that means that
the inside your Python function you can
you can actually modify the inputs and
that allows you to modify things in
place these are a couple of other
examples of layout specifications so for
example if you had a lot of matrix
vector products that you wanted to
compute lots of matrices and lots of X's
you want to multiply them then you would
use this layout specification taking you
from M by n input and an end length
input to NM length output this second
example shows one of the limitations of
the layout format which is that all the
all the lake all the sizes have to be
symbolic so you can't write a concrete
value so for example if you wanted to
declare a GU from that would compute the
maximum and the minimum of an input
array the output would be two things
that you can't you can't declare it as a
similar but sorry you can't declare it
the output is being of length 2 instead
you have to use two scalars thank you so
that's pretty much it for sort of the
brief tour of number in if you want to
have a look at the first set of tutorial
acting exercise if you manage to
download them if not I've got the URL
for accessing them at up there then I'll
try and help out if there's any problems
especially if there's any problems
getting set up at the moment and and
then I'll come back and talk a little
bit more after you had to go with the
tutorial exercises in about 10 or 15
minutes are there any questions at the
moment hey type specified
is there any performance so religious
it's optional specify the types and it's
normally not worth doing because number
figures out what the types are at the
time of the function call for the
vectorize decorator you might wish to
specify a list of different types and
the author and the order in which they
are the order in which they can be the
order the order in which they
prioritized and the reason for doing
that is you may want to make sure that
something with for example with the flow
32 input doesn't get cast up to a flow
64 inside the second section of the
first tutorial about the vectorize
decorator there is the kind of an
example about about doing that as well
um so all right now there's no support
for opencl and the was that there was a
branch a while ago where we try to do
that but it was sort of very do it was
very difficult to make it work very well
because so as I understand it there's
different memory spaces for different
for different pointers and it was
difficult to get that to work
efficiently because we kind of assume
that the memory space is flat and all
the pointers are in the same memory
space in number with the second bit of
the presentation that I was going to go
on with after you've had some experience
with the first tutorial exercise so the
plan nail was to talk a bit about the
intervals a number and how it works you
can get a bit of an understanding and
what kind of things work well with it so
the things we want to talk about next
are the dispatch process and the
compilation pipeline then I'm going to
talk a little bit tight
typing so you can understand how things
are typed in it how to get around type
inference problems but then I'll talk
about a bit about the different modes of
compilation so what you were going to
see in a tutorial exercises was that
when you use the JIT decorator there's a
little bit of an overhead on jetted
function calls so that would mean that
you would need to that would mean that
you would need to make sure that was
enough work done inside you jetted
function so that the speed-up of that
function overcomes the overhead of the
function call so the reason for this
overhead in call entity functions is
because each time the function call
happens was a dispatch process that
number has to do so number doesn't
compile code every time you call it
instead it maintains a cache of compiled
versions of functions of the function
where each of those compile versions is
specialized to the particular type type
to the arguments so the first thing one
was going to try and do is retrieve a
compiled version from that cash and to
do that it's got to look at what the
types of the arguments in this function
call are then you can compare those to
the types that are in the cache if it
does find a match then it can retrieve
that version but if not it's got to kick
off the compilation pipeline to build a
new specialization once we've got a
compiled version of the function then we
can't call that on the arguments we've
got because there python objects so they
need to be marshaled into native values
for scalars that's copy in the value and
for arrays it's getting the point is to
the data then can call the native code
function and it will get a native return
value it's got to be Marshall back into
Python this is so when compilation
happens this is the pipeline it goes
through first of all it calls the Python
compiler so that it will turn the Python
source into Python bytecode then it does
some analysis on that bike code to build
control and data flow graphs and then a
number intermediate representation after
that it can do it does type inference to
generate a type for everything in the
intermediate representation and then it
lowers that intermediate representation
to llvm intermediate representation
and from there llvm generates the actual
target machine code now normally you
won't have any problems with these
stages these first four boxes at the top
things tend to go smoothly they're
waitin to get problems with me in China
convert co2 use number it's during the
type inference stage if something's
badly typed or something's gone wrong
with typing then you can get errors
coming out of that stage you can also
get errors coming out of the lowering as
well if something that's normally
because something's badly typed it's
managed to sneak past the type inference
or the type checking stage so next we'll
look at type inference so that you can
understand how to avoid problems there
but why do we actually need to do this
the reason is that native code is
statically typed with Python code isn't
so number has to do something to
determine the type of every argument
intermediate value and return value in
the function it does that by propagating
type information from the arguments
through to the return values they can do
that because for every some for every
function that it supports it's got a
mapping from input types to output types
and it's got the data flow graph of the
function so it knows where to propagate
those inputted and outputted types so to
understand it a bit better we'll have a
look at this example function will
assume that it's called where a is a
float 32 and be as a float 32 at the
beginning of time the type inference
face it only knows the types of these
two arguments then when it propagates it
can deduce the type of C because if you
had a float 32 to a float 32 you get
another float 32 then it can deduce it
to the return type because that comes
from the type of C which is float 32 so
that's a straightforward example the
Taipings finished and the function can
be compiled where it becomes a bit more
complicated is when you have when you've
got control flow involved because you
can have multiple different types
assigned to the same variable it along
along different paths and when those
paths merge you have to do something to
unify the different types that came from
the different paths so
simple this example of the Select
function again will assume that a and B
are of type float 32 now inside the F
branch the type of Records did used to
be float32 inside the else branch the
type of rep is assumed to be float 32
now at the point of the return statement
the control flow merges so they've got a
tight for rep from both branches that
means that we don't have a single type
for it but instead we've got a set of
types in this case they're both float 32
so they can be unified into a single
time and then that's a successful typing
and the function can continue to be
compiled now if we look at another case
where it goes wrong I was real question
now if we look at another case where it
goes wrong this time if we assume that a
was a tuple then inside the F branch the
type assigned to read is a tuple whereas
in sorry in the F branch the type side
to write as a tool in the else branch
it's type is float 32 this time we build
this set over to every turn type of
types for the return statement and
because it's a tuple and a float we
can't unify them because there's no man
18 value that is suitable for
representing both these different types
so they thought the Taipings failed and
the function can't be compiled in
practice in practice what it looks like
if this has happened when you get a
unification error this number will give
you some kind of feedback like this so
this is one of the areas that I saw when
I was working on the examples for this
tutorial it told me that it's very well
at unified to object so unify object has
any type so that's telling me that
unifications failed now what I've done
in this case was to treat this variable
in one place as if it was an array and
in another place if it was a scalar so
I'd done something functionally
equivalent to this and that was why I
getting in that typing error
but some other kinds of typing errors
that you can get as well which when they
occur a number tries to give you some
kind of feedback about what the problem
is and the form of that feedback that it
gives you is normally it tells you that
some kind of function for some
particular types or and the collectors
on declared the name of that the
function that it gives you it's normally
kind of similar to the what the name of
the function would be in Python anyway
so in this example if you try to treat
an array as if it's a sorry a scalar as
if it's an array then it might tell you
that get item is undeclared for a
float64 with an n64 argument I often
find that this kind of error happens
when I'm getting a bit confused about
whether something is if I'm get a bit
confused about whether something is an
array or whether it's a scalar or if I'm
getting confused about which dimensions
of an array of working with i did also
say that you can get some air is coming
out of lowering and so I've got a couple
of examples of those areas just to show
just to help you with interpreting them
because they can't be quite cryptic so
this is one again that I got working on
the examples because broadcasting is not
supported the error message that you can
sometimes get there is it will tell you
that some particular internal value is
not a valid parameter name I just happen
to know from the experience of this
error that it means that broadcasting is
not supported but my general strategy
when trying to figure out where these
areas are coming from is just to comment
out different lines of the source code
and to try running again and again until
I can isolate the problem to a
particular line then when it's narrowed
down to a particular line you can
usually deduce what the actual issue is
this is something that can happen either
in lowering or typing sometimes this
happens really again when you're doing
broadcasting or also if perhaps if
you've got two different arrays that are
sliced differently or two arrays a
different era tea sometimes number will
say I don't know how to allocate an
array with let out a so if you look if
this happens then look around at the
broadcasting and slicing operations a
new function because they might be the
source of the error oh yeah near the
kind of error that can sometimes happen
if you treat an array as if it's a
scalar by mistake so this is one where I
was trying to check the truth value of
an array so it's saying I there's no
implementation of is true for a load
instruction so the load instruction came
from the fact that I was working with an
array and it sends you say I don't know
how to say tell if a pointer is true or
not and so all of the things that I've
just tipped act talked about to do with
typing are relevant for know python mode
which is the fastest mode of compilation
at numbers of course the reason it's
called know python mode is because all
the code that it generates there is a
native code it doesn't make any calls to
the Python interpreter or use the
interpreter in any way the default
behavior if something can't be tight for
know python mode or lowering fails in
know python mode isn't to give up and
throw those error messages back at you
but instead it falls back to a slower
mode called object mode where it does
support all the functions and types but
it does that by making calls to the
Python interpreter through the capi so
it goes a lot slower but no Python mode
if you want your code to go as fast as
possible then you need then you need to
have it running in know Python mode you
can force that to happen by adding the
know python equals true argument to the
JIT decorator some functions you just
can't compile in know python mode
because you'll have some types or
functions that are unsupported that you
need to be there that doesn't
necessarily mean that everything is lost
even when you're compiling in know
python mode
number will look for loops that only use
that use know python compatible types
and then it will lift them out into a
separate function and compile them in
know python mode so this can work well
for functions where you might have some
at some kind of allocation or conversion
at the beginning that can't be compiled
in know python mode but the bulk of the
work gets done inside an inner loop that
is compatible with no python mode so in
this example the beginning loop is using
if an array of strings is passed in is
using strings which aren't supported in
know python mode so it forces object
mode but this our for loop down the
bottom only uses integers and integer
arrays so it is no python mode
compatible it gets lifted out it's often
help it's helpful to be able to know
what's happening inside number in terms
of what the typing is or perhaps
sometimes to look at the generated code
to be able to see what's happened to be
able to see why object modes being used
or what might need to change to make
nope I that mode suit usable so there's
these methods but are all methods of
justed functions that you can call to
try and find out this information so if
you want to find out what number thinks
the type of everything in your code is
then you can call the inspector Heights
method and it will give you a string
back that will tell you that if you want
to see the code that numbers generating
then you can call inspect llvm or
inspectors ASM to get that those codes
as well if you want to understand that
performance a bit better so in the AI
file is quite a useful tool is the
number command-line tool which you can
use to generate an annotated HTML file
contain your source code and it'll also
annotate it with the number intermediate
representation and the type of
everything in inside the function any
types that are bad for know python mode
it will highlight red so you can see
what you might need to change and if
there's any loop lifting going on in
object mode that it will highlight those
loops in green so you can see where
that's happening as well
the plan was to sort of like allow a bit
of time sort of spending for going
through the tutorial exercises but if I
think like I say pulley the best thing
for me to do is to if everyone's managed
to get the materials I'll just carry on
sort of finished the presenter
presentation taught and then just let
people work through which all the
tutorial in their own time and I'm not
hanging around till the end of the
session so for the final part i was
gonna this week this is tutorial this
was sorry this is tutorial exercise 34
that had some example codes for you to
sort have a go at optimizing myth number
to try and try and use the JIT decorate
to try and make them go fast so each of
those example codes in the example
salute sorry examples folder it's got
some timing and some testing code so
that you can make changes and run it and
and then sort of see if you improve the
performance or it will tell you if any
difference in the output has been
introduced the inside that same folder
there's some example solutions as well
some of them are more optimized than
others so they they're all they've all
been got to the point where they run in
know python mode but some of them could
be a starting point for further
optimization rather than being
considered fully optimized so before
before that exercise I was just going to
over the next few slides just share this
kind of general approaches i use and i'm
trying to optimize code with number the
first thing i would try and do is just
try a damaged it decorator two functions
and then running the code or attempting
to run the code to see if it does run
sometimes it won't because of some
unsupported Python syntax so you might
need to make some modifications until it
does run digit decorator once it is
running the next thing I would do is use
the number command line tool to generate
an annotated version to see what's
happening it might be that some things
are running know python mode already or
that the some loot lifting going on as
well once you've once you've seen what's
going on you can try and convert it to
use know python mode by at one at a time
I didn't know python equals true
to your innermost functions and then
running making changes that are
indicated by your app to the types that
are indicated by your annotated version
until you've got that function to run in
nope I thermode then move on to the next
one sometimes you might do things that
you think would be speeding it up and in
actual fact those things can make it go
slower so it's a good idea to get busy
making changes just to keep your eye on
the performance of the code to make sure
you speeding up and not slowing it now
one of one of the things that a lot of
people bore that people that you used to
have to do in the past is tell the JIT
decorator what the types of everything
is the tights are very argument are but
that's not really necessary now because
number can always figure it out as soon
as you call the function anyway but
there is a lot of code examples on the
internet on sites like stackoverflow
that are relevant to older versions a
number where that was necessary so
you'll see a lot of these types out and
added to the JIT decorator but you don't
need them so it's not worth spending
time doing that once you've got things
running in know python load there's
often a few optimizations that there's a
couple of optimizations that i often
find your applicable so i'm going to
talk about these the first one is called
loop fusion and this is why what's
something that you can do if you have
two for loops next to each other butter
iterating over things with the same
shape and so to make that one to
potentially make that more efficient you
can merge those two loops into one loop
by merging the bodies and getting rid of
one of the four loops then once you've
done that that often opens up the
opportunity to do another optimization
which is called array contraction where
you convert things that are arrays in
two scalars if they don't need to be a
race so in this example if we assume
that what the array why it's only
purpose was to store temporary results
from the first loop and it's not
referenced after the for loop then
then there's no reason for it to be an
array now it's part of the same loop so
we can turn it into a scalar the reason
you want to do that is it reduces the
amount of memory either reduces the
amount of memory usage in that for loop
so that I can reduce the amount of cash
flashing in your CPU which might lead to
a performance improvement the other
thing to know is that when you write in
code when you just in co using number
it's a bit like see in that there's no
bounds checking on a elements so
sometimes you can start finding that you
get a really weird behavior going up or
perhaps the Python interpreter starting
to sector fault or throw up all the
weird error messages if that starts to
happen it's possible you're going out of
bounds so one way that you couldn't
detect that is you can set this
environment variable to disable jit
compilation all together and then run
again and then you Codel you're on to
the Python interpreter role and
compiling the code and that will throw
up if you are going out of bounds
anywhere if that's the case you can fix
the error while you why are you running
in that mode with the JIT disabled then
when you enable the JIT again if the
error is fixed hopefully that weird
behavior is going to go away so
I'll just skip on to my clothes like I
say I'll just finish the presentation oh
there was a few things that was going to
say at the end and then I'll be around
I'll stay around for the rest of this
session people working through the
tutorial if any questions come up so
something that I didn't have time to or
didn't expect to have time for in this
tutorial was releasing the global
interpreter lock if you can get your
functions to run in know python mode
then you can also get them to release
the global interpreter lock buy it in
the know Gil equals true parameter and
then you can use and then you can
execute them concurrently with
multi-threading but that doesn't give
you any protection from race conditions
so you need to make sure that your code
is doesn't have any races in it yourself
on Python 3 you can use the concurrent
futures threadpool executor but also
inside the number distribution there's
an example called no guilt pie that you
can have a look at with Python 2 m3
compatible I was just going to very
briefly mention number pro which has
some of the higher level features on top
of number I mainly focused on
parallelism so you can use it to write
multi-threaded you folks that run on the
CPU all that run on the GPU and it also
gives you access to some of the GPU
libraries from Python oh there's a few
blog posts that have seen in the past
I've enjoyed reading about number and I
thought that you might also enjoy i'll
be interested in reading them so all
these links should be on the version of
the slides that hopefully you've managed
to download and these are a few places
for getting more information about
number or contributing to it was the
gate repositories the number of Prayer
examples repository contains a lot of
examples that will work with number but
you will probably just need to change
the import to from it import number pro
to import number the reason that works
is that there used to be some features
that were in the pro that now been moved
into your source number as the number
users mailing list and I don't have the
link for it's a google groups you should
be able to find it by googling there is
also will provide some commercial
support for number so if you need some
help with accelerating your own co using
number both specific specific
enhancements or feature requests that
you'd be interested in that you can come
and talk to us also continue hiring so
if you think it might be time to move on
have a look at the greenhouse border
come and chat with the continuum booth
so after this tutorial I'm going to be
around the whole weekend so if you think
of any other questions about number
where you want to discuss anything
number related then come and find me
I've I'll probably hang it around the
continuing table when I can be so in the
next couple of weeks I was also planning
on doing a bit of number development and
perhaps live coding explaining what I'm
doing is I'm going along if you
interested in number internals or how
number works then you may be interested
in that I'll probably just announced
when I'm gonna do that on Twitter
finally I did offer a feedback survey
which I was gonna ask for feedback
mostly questions about the amount of
time I left for the tutor or the
tutorial exercises so don't be too harsh
anyway I hope in the end you do manage
to get some value out this tutorial and
I hope that you enjoy the rest of the
conference so I'm going to hang around
for the rest of the session and answer
any questions or if anyone wants any
help then in particular